[Music]
another broker get off
let me go so good that ped Lee's new
single love again from their upcoming
seventh studio album it's shot using
virtual reality technology a first for
the band the song is already a huge hit
with 1.4 million global stream so far
really is hard to believe though that
frontman jacob hoggard still gets
nervous releasing new music after so
many years in the biz hey what's up et
Canada I'm Jake Hogan from Headley and
welcome to the set of our brand new
music video for love again
this gunfire
it's very early and I'm doing this for a
minute so I know better than to just be
like pop a bottle we got another one
well it seems as though everyone is
loving Headley again with their new try
[Music]
and I've been working on this song for
eight months so you put everything you
have into something like this and all
you can going to do is let it go at the
end of the day and so to let it go and
have that kind of response back means
the world the single marks the beginning
of a new era for Headley they've shaken
up their lineup parting ways with
original drummer Chris Crippen there was
never a hesitation that this would have
been the end of Headley because we're
constantly evolving it's how we've gone
from a little pop punk band twelve years
ago to the artists that we're today and
I think it's a gradual and really
natural process that we have to always
be open but as the band puts the
finishing touches on their new album
cageless out September 29th tank up says
new member Jay piss fitting right in
he's a natural at this you know we've
known him for a long time he's a close
family friend and he's worked for
Headley for a long time I'm enjoying
watching him enjoy this process as these
kind of finding his footing and then
sort of his place in the interview
process and a lot of different elements
of what we do that are new for him